this is just a lot of content two full
pages and let's also forget that this
person is still a student and I know
that the general rule is that up to two
pages is okay I think more than two
pages is really bad you should not do it
but I would still recommend you to go
for the one pager layout and also one
page in general helps you much more to
really focus on your awesomeness so
daily the impression that you want to
create is that someone reads your CV and
every single line well every single line
just reads wow this is crazy impressive
impressive awesome never seen this this
is incredible but if you drag out the
content over two pages usually you don't
have enough things to really fill it
with that much awesomeness